[Musique]
euh
[Applaudissements] c'est
une grosse opération et, euh,
en fait, là où nous en sommes, nous le faisons actuellement
ou
dans l'est et le nord, c'est en fait
même loin des zones de conservation, loin des
zones protégées, c'est pourquoi il est très
important de savoir  nous avons toujours
concentré nos activités sur les
zones protégées,
mais pour la première fois, nous allons même
au-delà des zones protégées
parce que le gouvernement national veut
savoir où se trouve la faune sauvage.
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle nous faisons tout cela
est que  qu'il sera
[Musique]
capable ou de donner à une institution l'
opportunité de prendre
des décisions qui guideront en termes de
gestion de la faune dans le
pays [Musique]